well we are in full fall and
thanksgiving mode now and if you are
planning to entertain guests for the
holiday we have some tips for how to wow
them joining us today is brook fritz
from clover and stem with some fall
decorating tips and i can 100 vouch for
her skills because brooke actually did
the flowers and some of the decor at my
wedding it was so much fun i was so glad
to be part of it you made my dream come
true and i think you're making
everyone's thanksgiving dreams come true
let's talk a little bit about the
inspiration this is a beautiful setup
you have here and i'm liking the neutral
colors so run me through some of your
favorite things right now all right so i
actually got inspiration for this table
from this cute little chicken that i
found at a vintage market
and i wanted to go with a farm fresh
feel so i decided to go with creams and
natural colors and browns and rustic the
rustic vibe so i started with the table
runner cream table runner love it and
then i added a wood
plank okay and then i pampas grass is
super popular right now all the brides
everybody loves pampas grass so we did
some small pampers grass arrangements
mixed with a little bit of dried florals
just to add a little bit of texture i'm
going to say i've never seen one off
campus before they're so cute so cute
right they're so popular and something
else that has caught my eye on this
table i have to ask you about in the
center of each table you have little
popcorn kernels right yes i do jillian
so i um my mom she started this
tradition and when we were little we
would go around the table after
thanksgiving dinner and we'd hold up a
kernel and we would say what we're
thankful for
so we continue that tradition in our
family so every table has a kernel of
corn that is so cute i'm going to have
to incorporate that into my thanksgiving
dinner because i love that i think it's
really special just to go around the
table and talk about what you're
grateful and thankful for and so this is
a beautiful setup for the adults but i
want to move over here for a minute
because you can tell this is for the
kids but this is so cute tell me about
this turkey is the center okay so this
turkey is all edible
except for the nose okay but anyways so
this turkey we just made out of grapes
and the kids can help you make them this
uh we did tables i mean i'm sorry we did
uh plates with um
little turkey
gift bags that has candy and treats
something that's so cute yeah a turkey
leg yeah i love it
what is this underneath here you have
little pumpkin cutouts underneath here
we have some um what you're thankful for
so the kids can write on them and say
what they're thankful for but we covered
this table
with
paper and then we added some crayons so
the kids can just color and have a good
time and be chill and have fun together
so um and also we did some little cute
banners on here that says thankful i
love all of this just such simple ideas
but really takes your table to the next
level and i mean i want to sit at the
kids table because it looks so fun but
just coming back here before we have to
wrap up yeah do you think it's really a
great idea to pick one piece let's say
and kind of center the whole table
around it that's kind of how my mind
works when i find something i love then
i was like okay yes that's what i want
to do for my holiday scape or that's
what i want to do with whatever i'm
doing that's kind of how i plan
everything as a round one center well
one item can lead to a beautiful setup
like this that's all so beautiful and i
found you through a mutual friend but
then i found your social media and you
put all of your photos on there of all
your inspiration is that where people
should go if they want to connect with
you yes at clover and stem on instagram
is where you could find me and you ran
this company with your daughter right so
it's all family run which i absolutely
love and all of your work is so
beautiful i feel like we're going to be
seeing more of you here in las vegas now
because you got all the good tips thank
you so much thank you so much bro check
her out on clover and stem and we will
send